live on your monday morning time taking
now on an art contest for school kids
now this would make a great cool at
school story for friday unfortunately
that's the deadline for entering the
contest it is the storm water pollution
awareness poster contest for any k-6
student in nevada several organizations
including the nevada department of
transportation working together to raise
awareness about the fact that in nevada
anything that goes down any storm drain
is going directly into local waterways
without treatment so they have two
themes for the contest one only rain
should go down storm drains and two easy
everyday ways to prevent water pollution
so the winning posters are going to be
featured in a 2022 calendar with the
first place poster as the cover this is
an earlier one so we have links to the
contest and how to enter in the online
version of this and all of our driving
you crazy stories when you go to our
webpage eight newsnow dot com click
traffic then driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone something's driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight newsnow.com